hi good afternoon I am asked z allison
louis authorization and this is my best
buddy hi i'm auth n also known as
authentication I manage identities your
users groups sign-in policies and
directory sync and I contracts s
management meaning who can do what on
which resources and together we're known
as I am alright let's do a Rio Rancho so
I am very well I'm a product manager on
the Google cloud platform team and I'm
Jason Collins a cloud deployment
engineer we're here to talk to you today
about I am how to do Identity and Access
Management on Google cloud platform so
this is our agenda today I'm gonna lay
down some foundational bits on identity
it's a little bit you know dry talk gets
much better when Ray gets back up on
stage to talk about Access Management
and it's the best practices and then the
talk really reaches a fevered pitch when
we bring up a couple of customers who
are doing some really innovative things
on Google cloud platform with security
at scale ok so on Jesus on do Google
cloud platform we want to make sure that
only specific users can perform
particular actions I'm going to tell you
the first half of that story I'm gonna
tell you about identity management and
user authentication and then I'll give
you a quick demo of it as well so in the
simplest sense you can you just use
Google accounts to access the Google
cloud platform but the issue there is
that you don't have any centralized
management over these accounts so for
organizations it's a much better option
to use Google for work to the user
management to create and manage the
accounts and credentials now note I'm
just talking about the Google for work
user management aspect
you don't have to use the dot the the
applications like Gmail Docs and
calendar though you can they're pretty
awesome and I recommend them so what
this does in particular is it gives you
a single place to manage and control
your accounts and in particular it gives
you an easy way to suspend bad accounts
quickly because Google is managing the
login you get all the benefits and
security of the Google login screen and
the password reset mechanisms we have
session and device management tools that
help you know how our users are
accessing and where they're logging in
and when and we also detect suspicious
activity and we can configure it to to
alert you ok so this is a great option
for many companies it's the option I
chose as the CTO of a company named
vendas de before I joined Google now on
the other hand many of you probably
already have an identity system that
works great for you and you're
comfortable with in this case you can
enable single sign-on or SSO between
Google and that identity system and you
can continue using all the practices and
processes that you have in place today
with SSO configure whenever an author an
authenticated user is trying to access
the system we'll bounce the user over to
your ID system to get their get
credentials for them
okay now the corresponding a user
account needs to exist in Google so we
have to sync up the usernames between
your system and our system and to help
with this google has a tool called dads
or Google Apps directory sync and what
this tool does is it syncs identities
and groups from your LDAP over to Google
we'll talk a lot more about groups in
the second part of this talk so
federated identity using single sign-on
using SSO is used today by large
organizations like coca-cola and smart
technologies and I'll demo SSO for you
in a couple minutes to configure SSO
it's really a simple process all you
need to provide are three lane
into your existing authentication system
one for sign-in one for sign out and one
for change password and the change
password link really could be anything
because it's not actually part of the
auth flow our SSO is built on sam'l 2
which is a secure industry standard
protocol for exchanging user assertions
and assertions are just basically facts
about the user that Google will trust to
prevent tampering sam'l allows the
assertions to be signed digitally signed
so that we can verify that the
information originated from you and has
not been tampered with tampered with if
your if your identity system sorry to
allow that to work you have to provide
one more piece of configuration and
that's the digital certificate that
we'll use to validate the signature if
your identity system today doesn't
support sam'l 2 you can use third-party
identity management plugins like ping
and octa and others to bridge that gap
so let's take a little bit of a look at
this estimate of sam'l exchange there it
is in all its glory isn't it wonderful I
hope you can read this at the back I'd
like to take some time to go through
each of these lines in detail and and
and describe what's happening so let's
start at the top all right I'm just
kidding I'm I really do like this stuff
and if you want to talk about it come
find me later we could talk but I'm not
gonna make you sit for this I see some
people who kind of turn in for the doors
so suffice to say what we do is we
redirect the user to your identity
system with a sam'l request you
authenticate the user and redirect back
to Google with a signed sam'l response
in particular containing the username we
that username identifies the appropriate
account on Google side we create a user
session and we got to use your access so
in short a whole bunch of redirects and
this is typically transparent if users
already signed in there's some XML goop
and a signature and boom the users
logged into Google
so I'd like to do a demo of this can we
just flip to the demo please
great so a typical case would be that a
developer or DevOps person wants to
access the cloud console to do something
like start a VM or check logs or a just
a firewall rule and so to do so they'd
point the browser to the console so all
right so they're headed to the console
because the user is not authenticated
we're gonna do we're gonna see some
redirects happen okay so first of all
we're at this Google screen asking for a
username you know there's no password
here because we don't know if we need to
have a password or not in single sign-on
Google doesn't have any of the passwords
or even any of the password hashes so we
have to ask the user what domain they
want to authenticate to for example if
they enter it at gmail.com domain we
know that Google controls the
credentials it has to be responsible for
gathering for the login however if they
enter a domain that's configured for us
or so I've set up Westin widgets calm as
an SSO enabled domain Google will see
that and redirect the user to the
configured sign-in like great it worked
so here we are at Maya design challenge
to login screen for Western widgets and
this is where you gather the credentials
for the user and you might do that in
this case through password or maybe use
a facial recognition or a chimp plant
chip implant or something crazy like
that Jake at West and widgets comm so
when I authenticate this login system is
going to generate a sam'l response
containing the username it will sign it
with a digital certificate redirect the
user back to Google Google is going to
validate the signature it's going to
look at the username it's going to find
the corresponding account create a user
session and then redirect the user to
the cloud console where they're all
hedid so keep an eye on that URL bar up
the address bar and see these redirects
in action here all right we have made it
to the cloud console and you can yes and
you can see that I am logged in as the
user I intended to be logged in as Jake
this same technique can work anywhere
you need an OAuth access token as well
so so when you go to give an OAuth 2
access token the user has to grant that
and so we need to note that dkd user so
you flip into the OAuth flow and then
that will flip into the auth flow which
will ultimately go through the single
sign-on process so this same technique
works for the g-cloud command line
interface so the Google of the cloud SDK
and it also works for any API is that
you use OAuth as well you notice that
there is a sign out link here and
remember in the configuration we had a
sign out configuration as well and so
when I click this this is gonna sign me
out of both Google and your on-premise
system so if I go ahead and click that
I've logged out of both systems now so
I've achieved single sign out all right
so one other quick demo here Google App
Engine is an excellent platform as a
service to easily and quickly build a
line of business applications so for
example order management or customer
customer support systems human resource
information systems things like that but
how can we secure those apps with your
with your identity system with Google
App Engine this is literally one line of
code away first of all what we want to
do is configure the App Engine
application to be scoped to your domain
so in case of Western widgets I can set
it up so that only Western widgets users
can have access to the application then
in my optimal this is the wrong window
this is the right window
all I need to do is add one line of code
here's the single line of code that's
actually a lot of configuration it says
login required I put that on my handler
I save that and deploy that so imagine
this is the intranet app for Western
widgets I will go to the intranet and
again because I'm not authenticated the
login required tells Google App Engine
that we need to kick the user to the
authentication flow whoa that is not my
app at all I've been hacked there we go
I don't know what I typed before so here
I am at the login screen hey did you
notice that we didn't hit that Google
screen that asked for the username like
we did last time in this case because
the App Engine application is scoped to
Western widgets Google already knows
where it has to send the user to get the
authentication information so I can go
ahead and login yet again
and again redirection madness ensues and
Here I am at my intranet app so you can
see once again I am logged in as the
right user and the Google App Engine
user API makes this very easy to get to
get the username for the user so there
you have it
to get single sign-on configured with
Google cloud platform all you need is
three links into your existing identity
system and a digital certificate and
you're off to the races piece of cake
so now I'm going to throw it over to Rey
for the much cooler part of the talk
once we know who the user is how can we
control what they have access to and can
you just flip back to the slides please
there you go ray okay thank you Jason
so now your user has been authenticated
in your system the next thing we want to
make sure you can get them to do is to
get authorized to access the right set
of resources so let's talk about the am
part of I am access management meaning
who can do what and which resources the
can do what part is defined by an IM
role now when you think about it most of
the time when you're trying to do any
meaningful operation it takes more than
just a single permission in this example
if you're trying to get somebody to be
able to manage the VM instances in a
project they need you know computer
instances or you know get and create and
delete and start and stop and so on so
we group these permissions into an IM ro
chip simplify your management experience
to grant the right permissions to user
you grant a user one or more I am rose
resource so in this example here we're
giving a group of users the instance
admin role on project a which allows
them to then go and manage the GCE VM
instances in the project now this is
what the API looks like to set anion
policy you call the set iron Policy
method and the resort
we're setting the policy things we
already know where the resource is the
body of the policy contains the other
tree parts in there I am equation the
rows and there which members you're
granting each row to so as you can see
in this example here a member can be a
number of different things
it can be a user a group a service
account which we're going to talk about
later as well as if you want to share
with everybody in a domain you can just
put a domain name there and if you want
to share with the world so you have a
very public storage bucket you can
specify authenticating users you use the
set method to set the policy on resource
and get it back with the get method
standard stuff and then there's this
method called test hi and permission and
this is used for you to check if a user
has the permission to execute a very
specific operation and it comes very
handy if you're building your own custom
tool your custom UI and you need to
decide whether to show a height of a
pattern for user depending on what
permissions they have so these methods
on a project level have our eg8 so now
you can use the API to programmatically
manage your project permissions now
let's talk a little more about the road
if your current GCP user you probably
already have used one of the the three
rows in a project level owner editor and
viewer many of you have told us that
they are not granular enough for you to
really lock down your permissions right
so we know three is obviously true for
you
let's try 23 we're happy to announce
that we have just launched over 20 new I
am rows across a set of a major services
let's look at some examples you after
want to allow your developers to be able
to access labs so they can do debugging
but you might not want to expose the
rest of the production projects to them
and you can do so by granting them the
log viewer role so they can only look at
allowance if you have a CIL CD system
and you want to allow them to
automatically update the pits on GA and
GCE you can grab them in the App Engine
deploy a row or the compute instance
and that way they can make the updates
on instances without being able to
access data in storage you can use one
of the data flow rows to give your data
scientists access to interact with data
flow jobs without allowing them to
accidentally deleting the VMS running
underneath today a flow in a common use
case for GCS is to allow a user or
service to upload data and you can lock
down the permissions in that case by
granting them the storage object create
a row which allows them to create new
objects but not have the permission to
access or delete the existing data in a
storage bucket and you know you might
say wait wait but there are a couple of
rules I really need and then not on that
list
what I gonna do for me right I still
have lot nodding head well our teams are
working very very hard on the next wave
of rows as well as giving you the
ability to eventually make your own
custom rows now can we flip over to the
demo screen I'm going to show you how
these roles working ring for real so
here I have a project where I have the
traditional owner row which means I can
do just about anything in a project
where I can look at you know compute and
storage and my API usage as well as
billing data what I can also do on a
project is to go over to the permissions
tab where I can see you know how many
rows I have assigned to which users as
you can see I have a number of human
users who have the owner row and then I
have a number of service accounts for
have the editor role and to assign
additional rows to people I need to do
is to click this Add members button
which brings about a dialog I can type a
user's email address and then select one
of the rows to assign to them now let's
come to the second project where I don't
have the owner editor URL and therefore
shouldn't be able to see most of the
information here so the dashboard is
hidden from me because I can't see the
data I also can't says app engine or
storage billing however I do have one
on this project which is to compute
instance adding role so what this role
allows me to do is to come to the
compute pay and be able to see a list of
my VMs and control the VMS you can see
the patterns like you know creating
strands and create instance groups
available to me because of that method
we talked about test iron permission
checks that I have permission to execute
these operations okay can we go back to
the to those slides thank you all right
since I am policies are set on resources
let's talk a little more about how
resources are defined resource is not
just a random flat list of VMs and Jesus
buckets they have relationship with each
other and we can use these relationships
to simplify how you can manage policies
if your current user you've already used
this concept called a project a project
is a basic container of resources and a
trust unit the roles that we have just
seen the slides in a demo can be
assigned on a project level and when you
do that they get inherited by all the
resources underneath the project so for
example what we just saw you know you
you assign the instance admin wrote a
set of users then these users can manage
all the instances waiting the project
you don't have to go on permission each
individual VM instance and when you're
out of scalars things up another new
instance you don't have to go and hurry
up and add a policy for your adding to
be able to do that job they get us
through inheritance now some of the
resources underneath the project can
also be permissioned individually for
example pops up topics or GCS buckets
and I know a lot of you want to be able
to do that and other types of resources
especially VMs come up a lot right
our teams are working hard to find a
solution Chell are to be able to do that
some of you have been a DCP user for a
while and you know as a usage grows you
might end up with a large number of
projects and then they can get a little
unwieldy to manage a scale and that's
why we have introduced now the
organization node the organization node
is a layer that sits above your projects
it's a company
what note for managing your TCP
resources if your Google for customer
when you enable the organization node
then from there and whenever any
identity from your domain goes and
creates a new project whether it's a
service account a user when a create a
project the project will automatically
belong to organizational so no more
shadow projects the rogar means you have
control of it all and they're a cup of
rows that we have specifically designed
for the organization node one is the
organizational admin just like what the
name says it allows your admin to have
central visibility and control of all of
the projects or of the resources inside
our company
another interesting ROS the project
creator role so if you want to actually
control who in your company can sting up
new projects to to create new resources
you can use that road to to define that
set of users also other roles that you
saw the when we when we look at the
project demo they can also be granted on
the organization level and again because
of the policy inheritance when they
granted for the organization they get
inherited by other projects and other
resources inside your organization so if
you have a networking team you want to
allow a networking community manager or
the networking a company you can grant
them the network admin role on the
organization level which will allow them
to manage or the other approach other
networks in our of the projects inside
your company the organization node is in
alpha right now so if you're our current
Google for work customer you can work
with your account manager of sales
partner to have one enabled for it for
your company so let's take a look at a
demo switch over thank you so here I
have a company which I commit who
conveniently named the next demo company
which has an organization node and once
you have an organization OD get its
extra drop down list which is cardi
organization picker where you can select
to look at things from your organization
perspective and when you do that there
are two tabs available to you when it's
a projects tab where you get a see the
entire list
producing said of her company regardless
of whether you personally have specific
permission that's granted on a project
you get a through inheritance and a
second tab is the permissions tab where
you can view and manage permissions
granted on the organization level and
here you can see many of the the i''m
roles that we talked about on a project
level can also be granted on the
organization level and the same dialog
and members again will allow you to
grant additional roles to two people on
your level so if we look under project
creator you can see that I have granted
this row to my entire domain which means
everybody in my company can go and
create new projects switch back to the
slides okay all right so when we
previously told you that we've already
told you everything about identities
that wasn't completely right sorry Jason
there's still one type of identity that
I don't want to talk to you about here
which is a service account now service
account is not an identity for your
human beings like users or groups but
rather it's the identity that can be
used by a program to attend a cage to
access GCP api's your users can go to a
web page like jason just did and type in
username password and logging well your
program isn't going to do that so
instead they authenticate with keys when
our more keys can be created but for
each I am service account and since keys
basically give you access to your
resources they're very sensitive data
you want to you want to take good care
of them if your programs run on App
Engine or compute engine then you don't
have to worry about it because we manage
the keys for you and we regularly rotate
the keys to guard against leaking if you
run a program somewhere else you can
download the keys to be used in your own
code but keep them safe now the other
curious thing about service accounts is
that a service account can be both an
identity and a resource me Ryan policy
and this is why if you're using service
accounts for your VM to run or to access
to
PAP is UVM's need permissions to go to
these api's and that permissions are
entered through the service account
but in that case you're granting I am
roles on certain resources to the
service account and a service account is
acting as an identity the identity of a
VM however you also want to make sure
that you can't you control who has
access to the service accounts you don't
want any random person to be able to
just bring up a VM and use a service
account and then they get access to all
your resources and not better off that's
not good so you can actually permission
the service account for example grant
when ammo of your specific users will
need to be able to do things with these
VMs the service account actor role to
allow them to assume the identity of the
service account now in this case in this
specific policy the service account is
the resource by one commission another
feature that we have launched recently
is pervious service account why do you
need that you need that so that your
different VMs in your project can run
with different identity and thus get
different sets of privileges so in this
example here in your project a you have
two components component a needs to
manage and therefore B the editor on
project B whereas component 2 just needs
to view a storage bucket you don't want
to grant your entire project
mims the superset of our of these
permissions because that goes against
our security best practice so instead
what you do is to have true difference
that different service accounts
representing these two different
components set of VMs and grant each
service account just a minimal set of
privileges that your VMs need to use to
operate you can also dynamically change
the privileges granted to the the
service accounts while the VMS are
running without having to recreate a VM
all right so now you know what you can
do with the new i''m features let's go
through some security best practices to
talk about how to secure environments
first half our principle of least
privilege
this applies to all three parts of your
I am policy they identities the rows as
well as a resources what not to do is to
grant everybody
the owner role are your entire
organization I know we are good friends
want to share but this is risky because
then any accidental mistake or an
intentional hack can just bring down
your app or leak your data so instead
you want to be very specific and very
deliberate in your policies for example
granting your security admin group a the
security admin role which allows them to
change SSL certs and power rules and
specific projects that they need to work
on use groups managing permissions on
individual users can quickly get those
cumbersome and error-prone so you want
to use groups let's say you have a set
cup team you want to create a group for
them so as new members come into a
company and join a team all you need to
do is to add them to the group and not a
sudden they have the same privileges as
the rest of their peers and you might
want to assign more than just a single
row to the group
it depends on a job function for example
here you know your security team might
need a security admin Road to do the
firewall SSL certs change and a lock
view or row just to monitor what's going
on and then as time goes on their job
function might change and the I am the
set of I am rows my change and now I
have to do to stay up to date is to
change instead of I am rows friend here
to your group again you won't have to go
and modify that for each individual
users and try to keep them consistent
they are in policy to allow you to
secure who can access your resources but
you also want to safeguard who can
change these policies which is also
granted through and I am permission as
well as who can change user group
membership because either of those two
can allow additional people to access
your resources
another way to safeguard your policies
is through out logging some of you may
have gone to the other log session
yesterday and have heard that we now
have support for our a lock or project
level permission changes and we're going
to be adding it for other resource
levels in the next
few months and if you use service
accounts we talked about her keys a
really sensitive data and you can guard
against leaking but regularly rotating
them you can do so by creating a news
new key and updating a program to use
the new key and then go remove the old
key an hour of these AP is including the
AP has to list and create and manage the
service accounts are proud of the I am
API which is now in beta so we promised
you this talk is going to keep getting
better now comes to the most exciting
part you're gonna hear from a couple of
real DCP customers on how they have used
the I M features first we're going to
have snapchat and as you know snapchat
runs on GC p and serves over a hundred
million users and without a private user
data snapchat has it's no wonder that
they really care about security and
privacy so we have the patch from the
snapchat security team
thanks ray so for those of you that
don't know what snapchat is very
storytelling social network we have a
large number of users that always that
log in on a daily basis the current user
numbers are somewhere in upwards of 100
million plus daily users that actually
log in or interact with our servers
using our mobile apps viewing about 8
plus billion videos and thanks in large
part to the Google cloud and App Engine
were able to service that large number
of requests with a very small number of
Engineers for about a 200 plus
engineering size team and the other part
that has a as a security engineer the
other advantage that the cloud gives us
is very largely responsible for making
sure that the security of a project or
cross project interactions are secure
but we don't have to really worry about
how the underlying infrastructure is
built that is Google's responsibility
effectively what we're trying to what we
are responsible for is understanding
very Google security contract ends and
pick it up from there and prior to the
advent of the organization node we had a
very strict policy around creating new
projects because a anybody could create
a project and we wouldn't even know that
such a project existed so with the
advent of the organization node I think
it will help us we'll probably have a
lot more projects and next I'm going to
introduce a customer that apparently has
a lot more lot larger footprint than
what snapchat does that I'm going to
introduce David from the Google stack
ops team hi my name is David and I work
on the Google security ops team and
basically my job is to make sure that
all of googles usage of GCP is is secure
and protected what most of you might not
know is that Google is for a while now a
fairly heavy user of GCP itself we have
over 100,000 GCP projects running out in
the wild already running all sorts of
interesting apps from our HR tooling to
compensation
- internal incident response management
tools and sub - we even have a social
network just say anyway oh there we go
so so bash tonight we're going to talk
to you a little bit about how do we two
things how we secure the the access is
within a project and segment data within
a project and then also how once you've
gotten to a hundred thousand projects
how do you secure the hundred thousand
projects that you have to make sure that
they're doing something sensible so one
of the things that we like to do at
Google is we like to make sure again
that everything has as few privileges as
it needs to get its job done and so what
that means for Google anyway is that
typically services are given access to
sensitive data and customer data but the
engineers the developers and reliability
engineers don't actually get any
permission to the sensitive data instead
they're given access to manage the
services and they can if they need then
go access the data through those
services where business logic to secure
and lockdown access can be can be can be
done very specifically so I think as we
already mentioned prior to the advent of
I am there are pretty much three roles
editor viewer an actor and editor of
your and owner so if a project has user
data pretty much even the least
privileged or of viewer means nothing
from a security perspective because once
your viewer you pretty much have access
to the entire data in the project which
is a huge security risk for us so we one
can always do some hacks by basically
revoking viewer access to certain
buckets or to datasets but that still
gets unwieldy so thanks to I am I think
in the last couple of weeks where it was
the floodgates were released and we
could actually start using I am we've
been able to significantly reduce the
number of developers that actually have
access to these coarse-grained roles and
we've as Ray already mentioned while
some of the roles that helped us a lot
is the log viewer because most times
developers are actually just trying to
debug problems so they can use the log
via role to get access to the logs the
App Engine viewer
which gives them a quick snapshot in the
App Engine Service admin role which
allows them to do traffic splitting to
run some experiments and also change the
versions or rollback versions in case
there are any issues and also we're
pretty excited of what the future can
hold because with things like the App
Engine deployer we can change some of
our workflows and then once those
workflows are changed I think we can
have a we will have a much larger
reduction in the number of developers
that actually have access to these
coarse-grained roles
Tim thanks Abeche now continuing with
the theme of locking down access to
resources I wanted to touch on the
subject of micro services especially
within GCE apps and in GCP new with I am
as we mentioned was the ability to
create multiple service accounts on a
single project and with this capability
we can basically let each of these
service accounts represent one of our
micro services give it access to just
the data it needs and then spin up a
fleet of VMs associated with that
service account and basically then do
that again and again and again making
sure that each each service only has
access to what it needs so what do you
think about that so the possibilities
that this opens up is pretty much
endless
so one of the the cool things you can do
with this is imagine you have a you're
trying to have two micro services in a
given project with the compute engine
service accounts of the past there is no
way for to realistically segregate the
accesses that each of those micro
services has so you could always hack it
up by creating a different service
account manually pushing those service
account private public keys to the
entire fleet but then like anybody that
can log into that box has access to the
private key
it gets pretty messy so imagine this
scenario we're talking about like Alice
has her own micro service Bob as his own
micro service only Alice can deploy code
to to her micro service fleet and so Bob
can deploy to his so the only person
that can actually deploy to it is
is the owners of the service account
what this allows you to do for example
each micro service could have its own
bootstrapping secrets or its own
encryption keys or data encryption keys
they're effectively tied down to that
compute engine service account and only
the owners of that micro Service can
actually deploy code to it
you can actually take it one step
further where Alice and Bob don't
actually have direct access to deploy
they actually delegate that authority to
a deployer service account which then
has the authority to deploy to these to
the fleet of micro service VM instances
which means the developers don't
actually have access to the to the raw
instances but they can always get to it
in case there's an emergency
and this alters is opens up the ability
to do true micro service to micro
service authentication because you have
the Imagineer these two computing and
service accounts nobody but Google has
the private keys of course Google is
trusted and given in that paradigm there
is no but nobody else that can actually
sign has that or act on behalf of that
service account and when the server
receives that are the target receives
that you can actually vouch for it that
this is indeed this message or GWT has
indeed been signed by that service
account and I can there is an
independent way for me to query that
public key so you actually can do true
micro service to Microsoft's
authentication without private keys
floating all around the planet so I
think this is pretty compelling for us
amen and I think one of the the key
aspects there is like when I when I when
I'm auditing my engineering source code
I don't actually have to care about what
they're doing with the private keys
anymore
right I don't have to make sure they're
deleting them rotating them oh my gosh
yeah huge so you know what else could be
cooler V V are we the nature or the
content of as one as one knows
everything that snapchatters or any
content that's shared on snapchat is f
amoral so we figured why not take it to
the next level and have and say the
developer access to critical resources
is also ephemeral and what if in a
steady stage nobody had access to
anything what are you feeling okay so
that Jeremy out the array gave us some
new functionality let's see what it does
for us okay so we basically built a Akal
easing infrastructure so imagine you
have an access controlled service that
has the ability to set an IAM policy on
a set of projects or the entire
organization now what you can do is
supposing an engineer wants access to a
resource the engineer can go into that
service say I will need access to this
resource specify a time and then that
access control service can actually go
back and check whether that engineer is
in the whitelisted set of users for that
particular resource that trying to
access if yes they're given that access
for that short period of time and then
automatically event the duration or the
lease has expired basically the the
service would do another set I am policy
without that user and the resource and
boom that resources the access to that
resource for that developer is gone it's
crazy
only snapshot would invent temporary -
world so now that we've solved the
project I am has solved the project is a
problem of project level security I was
hoping to move on to talking about my
favorite topic organizational level
security hang on hang on okay
what's that so I am has allowed us to
significantly improve our access control
posture but if you look at the gamut of
resources just go to the developer
console and see there is probably 25
different kinds of resources we've
gotten resource our roles first say
about seven or eight of them there's
just a whole gamut of resources for
which we need roles for example bigquery
data store tasks use of the whole gamut
of them that Ray will give us pretty
soon she's still gonna be on my number
one favorites on Google Hangouts and of
course we need custom roles because
there are each organization always has
has the need for doing something special
what if if Google allowed us the ability
to say take this role but I don't like
this particular functionality so instead
of a customer being able to create or
having to create an entire role from
scratch just minor tweaks to it and the
next thing that we're also we have
implemented or hacked together on our
own because the data store doesn't
actually have kind level permissions or
in namespace level permissions so in the
absence of that what we've done is
basically in the remote API we're
parsing the protobufs as they're coming
through we're constructing these objects
extract the namespace and the kind and
then we're doing Ackles on top of it so
far from ideal we would love for Google
to solve it and that's one more thing
that I'm hoping ray is gonna give us
pretty soon good point good point
thankfully I'm sure the IIM team would
be happy to know those lab jobs next
week there's one more thing sorry so
we've got enough X Googlers in our
company and any time we talk anything
about authentication and authorization
they tell me this super secure reverse
proxy that Google has that apparently
solves everything on the planet I can't
say the name because they'll probably
kill me mm-hm but let's call it a secure
reverse proxy that can effectively
perform any authentication any
authorization decision and force
additional levels of authentication Hey
tap your Yubikey you haven't tapped it
in more than five minutes tap it again
this is a sensitive resource so I'm
hoping that Google's gonna deliver us
that capability I have it on good
authority that some people are working
on these very problems to beche
cool thank you ah so now organizational
security so at Google we have a we have
a basic theory on organizational
security in that we don't really want to
get too involved in managing
micromanaging our engineers and what
they're doing we want to give them
generally free leash to do what they
need to do so long as it's reasonable
and 99% of the time it's irrelevant to
Google's security posture but sometimes
occasionally we get situations where
application needs to access secure data
company critical data or talk to other
services that are fairly important to
the company as a whole and that's where
my team tends to get more involved and
in in our life is in from my perspective
I think one of the biggest things that
this this basically rooted in is
understanding
what's going on inside the company from
like a 20,000 foot level and so the org
node policies that we now can apply let
us take actually snapshots of what's
going on in in all the Google owned GCP
projects and that's like an incredibly
powerful tool then after after we know
what's going on then we can start
reasoning about it and then we can then
try to make sure that only the right
kinds of things are happening either by
talking to the engineers who are
creating the projects or using the
projects or by actually going and
organizationally and shutting things
down that shouldn't be done or shouldn't
be allowed and what's super important to
me
I assume mostly to you is that I don't
actually get my team doesn't actually
need permission to go and read any of
the critical data or sensitive data of
the company we really just want to be
able to get a sense of what's going on
in the in the in the control point of
the system largely agree but I think the
one area because we have a lot of user
data in our projects any time a project
has user data pretty much the security
team kind of decides what they need
because developers always want access to
everything so the security team will say
hang on not not so much it's key let's
tweak it and identify the nature of the
application and then decide what
security policy should be applied it's a
good point thankfully I am was designed
with these kinds of these kinds of
issues in mind and it allows us to do
all sorts of interesting things it
allows my team to build interesting
tools to actually try to manage to
manage our problems and so one of the
things that we've done at Google is
we've introduced an onboarding workflow
so when new projects are created by our
engineers we can actually discover them
by listing at the organizational level
and we can basically see what the who
the people are who are creating and
using the project we can send them an
email saying faith by the way these are
the best practices for security and
these are the expectations this is how
you register for further security
reviews if that's necessary this is how
you actually go and get access to
critical resources etc etc etc another
thing that we've recently started doing
is doing a continuous scan of all the
virtual machines and all the resources
in use and actually sending those teams
a monthly reminder indicating what
they're doing what they're using
and if there's anything it looks like it
could be terminated like the ends that
could be shut down we give them the
suggestion that turn them off and the
best most secure VM is a dead VM so I do
you think I think it's great we've
pretty much followed the same philosophy
except in cases where of course as I
said earlier projects to use the data
and one example I want to give is
recently there was that March first open
SSL vulnerability was going to be a
vulnerability was gonna at least so
you're like ok what what is our
footprint priority the organization
umbrella we would have no way of knowing
it thankfully Rea whitelisted us we were
on the Alpha program so we went got
assigned a compute instance admin role
to a service account II made sure that
we were able to get an accurate
inventory of every virtual machine we
owned and then put populated the keys
also just to make sure that in case it
was heartbleed next we had the ability
to quickly go and patch thankfully we
didn't have to but the fact that the arc
node existed enabled us to actually have
the assurance that we know what we owned
it's a great story and now you guys can
do the same thing so another thing that
Google likes to do Suresh is pretty much
everything that we run in production
tends to be tends to go through a secure
not a secure but a source code review
and then gets committed to our source
control system and then from there only
from there does it get pushed to
production and previously before we had
the all the api's that we now have had
from I am it was actually kind of a
little bit hard we couldn't actually
ensure that everything had to be all the
policy updates had to be done by hand
but now we have a way of
programmatically managing apples and
other things so we can actually write
tooling that sucks from our source
control system scans all the projects
and make sure that they actually look as
we think they should be configured and
then if they're not we alert or we can
even use organizational organizational
level powers to just go and set them as
we need sounds cool so we actually do
something very similar for one part of
our apples because we're not Google we
don't have access to those internal
api's but you know what would be cool is
if you can actually open source some of
that
ah that's a great idea and somebody at
Google has already had that idea and
they're already working on getting it
through the process out the door to open
source it so soon we'll share all that
code cool looking forward to using it
ray can we turn it back over to you
thanks Ryan by the way thanks
so I hope you've enjoyed this talk
everything we've shown in this talk are
now available to you and our team we're
really excited to see what you can do
with these tools so if you want to get
in touch send us feedback thoughts
feature of crest this is how to email us
you can also come to the infrastructure
pools to chat even more about I am thank
you
you